what is machine learning
used often these days as synonymous with
magical magic it's a magic box of magic
and we open it up we sprinkle Magic on
the top of our business and Magic
happens
actually let's just put it bluntly
something far less glamorous machine
learning is a thing a labeler
essentially
it's an approach to making lots of small
decisions with data decisions like is
this email spam yes or no or what should
I bid on the next auction how do I move
a joystick
and if you want a computer to make
decisions for you
it's got to convert information input
data into an answer a label or a
decision via some kind of recipe now in
machine learning we don't hand craft
anything anymore now the program is Task
changes to feeding examples into the
system and it is the machine learning
algorithms job to stitch that recipe
together out of the examples